welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul
and like a bad out of hell the walking
dead has returned with a set of six
episodes
before we head into the show's final
season the finale culminated with a
negan-centric entry i felt in a lot
about his character and his urgent story
there's flashes of a christmas carol
here an actual carol here
and overall it leads to one of the most
introspective entries that the entire
show has had so far
jeffrey d morgan completely knocks it
out of the park as he searches for his
baseball bat
and the actor delivers a home run that
easily elevates his character to being
my favorite in the entire show
sorry coral now we're gonna be breaking
it all down but obviously there will be
heavy spoilers here
if you enjoy the video then please click
the thumbs up button and don't forget to
subscribe for breakdowns like this each
and every day
without the way huge thank you for
clicking this now let's get into the
walking dead
now we open with maggie walking with her
and glenn's son herschel the pair sing
you are my sunshine which in a cruel
twist of fate is what negan made call
sing him earlier in the series
negan made him do this because it was a
song that laura used to sing to him as a
child
and we see this repeated here once more
with a mother singing it with her son
like carl and rick negan has had a large
impact on the pair
because he of course killed glenn who
was both a husband
and father to them he was also alpha's
second in command when the whisperers
burned down hilltop
and there's clearly a lot of anger there
on her behalf
maggie is of course still frustrated
that negan has been allowed to live
and carol overseeing this interaction
decides to take things into her own
hands
she escorts negan out into the woods
namely to the hut that she and daryl
discovered
and tells him that the council recently
voted to banish him
however this is a lie and as per usual
carol has simply stepped in
and told negan this because she believes
it will avoid further conflict down the
line
carol like negan is someone who is very
headstrong
and can very much see the way things are
going and like him she somewhat uses the
attrix and deception
as a means of control though she's
nowhere near as villainous as he was
it is nice how they reflect one another
and both have used lies in their
leadership in order to shape things to
be a certain way
now negan of course has a lot of
skeletons in his closet
because unlike carol he led in a way
that was best for him
rather than how she handles it which is
what's best for the group
negan is very much haunted by the idea
of his past
and that night in the cabin he's visited
by the savior version of himself
this taunts him saying that there was no
way his past would ever be forgiven
and we cut to the character returning to
where rick slit his throat
we also see a flashback of michonne
saying that they left lucille out at
this location
and this very much speaks to negan's ego
he believed himself to be someone that
was vastly important
a symbol of fear that ruled over a
mighty kingdom however
when this tyrant was brought down not
even the things that made him infamous
were respected
and they were dumbed in the very spot
where he quote unquote died
after digging in the dirt he comes
across lucille once more
and this episode very much symbolizes
him not only putting his past to rest
but also the memory of his wife who we
meet in this entry
negan has believed that if he just
buries everything then it will be
forgotten
but he metaphorically and let riley must
dig it up in order to become a new and
better person
now we jump back in time to find him
tied to a chair whilst being
interrogated by members of a motorbike
gang
negan was out on the road trying to get
chemotherapy drugs for his wife
and they came across him and took him
captive turns out he's had his run-ins
with them in the past
and he sent them off on a wild goose
chase which they now seek retribution
for
they want medicine and negan has to
somewhat sell his soul in order to get
back to his wife
from here we get a further flashback and
catch him meeting laura for the first
time
who you may remember as a prominent
member of the xavius negan was trying to
rob her and her father franklin
but he's knocked down by the former
using the bat that later becomes lucille
after revealing that his wife had cancer
negan also confirms
that he was a high school gym teacher we
do a further flashback to six weeks
before this
when negan was treating his wife he's
trying to give her as much normality as
possible
but because of the almost endless swarms
of the undead she's unable to chill out
and watch
james bond movies negan won't let her
live and let die
thank you and he constantly heads out to
more and more dangerous situations
to ensure that she gets to die another
day thank you i'm here all week now
because of this
the time that the pair spend apart
becomes longer and longer
but negan sees it as being necessary due
to the trips being the only thing that's
keeping her alive
the moments that the pair spend together
are really touching
and watching negan sing you are so
beautiful to me
as we get flashbacks of their lives
shows how much he really cares about her
it's during these moments that we see
lucille kept a leather jacket that negan
bought himself when he was jobless
his wife was anger that he bought
himself a gift when they had spiraling
credit card debts
and it also showed that he was very
self-centered throughout the entry we
discovered that before the apocalypse
negan actually had an affair and this
further cements how self-serving the
character really was
lucille has forgiven him because since
the world went to crap
he's really shown her that he did love
her more than anything and it's clear
that she was a good influence on him
as we know in her death he returned to
being this self-centered person once
more
but we'll discuss how the character
comes full circle to how he was with
lucille at the end of the video
now unfortunately the generator keeping
the fridge going shuts down
and thus the chemotherapy medication is
ruined from here we get a flashback
within a flashback within a flashback
within a flashback
and see negan pre-apocalypse telling
kids to stop being [ __ ] on the
internet
never change negan never change now this
fills in a lot of the blanks about his
past
including the jacket story and also that
he assaulted someone when he worked as a
teacher
because of this he lost his job but
lucille stuck by him which is of course
reflected in him sticking by here when
everything around them ends
lucille is diagnosed with cancer the
next day which is also when she
discovers his affair
due to him lying about attending a
parole meeting after the cancer
bombshell drops he breaks things off to
focus
completely on his wife and we do see
that when it comes down to it
negan will be loyal to those around him
cut up one level in the flashbacks
and we see that lucille just wants negan
to stay and enjoy the time that they
have together
however negan wants more time with her
potentially due to his selfishness
and thus he goes out looking for doctors
in hopes of gaining more medicine
now i did say potentially there as it's
what anyone would have done
but it does further confirm that negan
always tries to get more than he should
and this always leads to a negative
outcome jump back to franklin and laura
who take pity on him
and the pair given medicine along with
lucille the phrase
what goes around comes around is said
and this becomes
a very important message cut to the
bikers
and negan gives up the location of
franklin and laura
negan could have saved them but instead
he abandons them to their fate and
returns to his wife
as the saying goes what goes around
comes around and this bad karma follows
the character home
where he discovers that lucille has
ended her own life and is now a zombie
this is heartbreaking for him and
because he was gone
it is possible that she thought that
he'd run out on her we don't know what
her final thoughts were but it's clear
that she didn't want to live anymore
and negan has wasted the time that he
could have had with his wife
negan burns her get some barbed wire for
the bat
and takes the leather jacket to the
haunting song you are so beautiful by
joe cocker
this scene gave me goosebumps as we
watched him transform into the villain
that we'd come to know and hate all love
because
i quite liked him now negan takes his
first life with lucille as he returns to
the bikers to kill them one by one
like a bow of hell so sorry i've already
done that joke
he rescues franklin and laura but it's
clear that he's a changed man
he recounts the time that he assaulted
the man which he lost his job over
and everything starts to make sense
negan and his wife were trying to listen
to their favorite song
but some drunk at the bar refused to
shut up and thus he
ended up taking his anger out on him it
really shows negan's dark aside
and with nothing in his life giving him
a reason to be good anymore
he's realized that the only thing left
to do is be as evil as he can
go to the present and we see a walker
slowly sneaking up on him
and he takes us out with the bat which
becomes the last stack that he ever does
with lucille
negan realizes that though he's still
seen as a villain
he's not and he has changed he says
goodbye to his wife
something that he's buried since she
died and the character burns lucille
promising that he will do her fighting
for her
going forward negan returns to the
community but something is different
about him
and he now wants to fight instead of
being cast out he's no longer expecting
to be forgiven
and though he knows maggie will likely
try and kill him he's not ready to give
up on the man he became
it's a thrilling ending and once more
shows that negan would rather face death
than be cast out once more
showcasing that he's made a home and
will fight for it no matter what
it's absolutely brilliant and i can't
wait to see the culmination of this arc
for the final
season obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the episode so make sure you
comment below and let me know
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
store on the 30th of april
in which we're giving away three copies
of zack snyder's justice league in 4k
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the episode
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
falcon in the winter soldier which will
be linked on screen right now
we went over the third episode and
talked about all the easter eggs in it
so it's definitely worth watching if you
want to know more
by the way thank you for sticking
through the video i've been paul i'll
see you next time
take care peace